Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan. Wir stehen vor dem Salon und unterhalten uns jetzt erst nochmal ganz kurz über Vogue-ness. Denn es ist ja doch so, dass das Thema, das wir da angeschnitten haben, durch den Zeitaufmacher viele Leute interessiert hat und ich will nochmal ganz ausdrücklich betonen, dass ich mich wahnsinnig darüber ärgere, wenn irgendwelche Leute, die nie für linke Positionen eingestanden sind, und im Sinne von Klassenkampf, jetzt schützen wir die Mieter oder sonst irgendwas, plötzlich sagen, ja das ist irgendwie schlimm, dass die Linken gar nicht mehr an die Arbeiterklasse denken.
Das war doch deren Aufgabe.
Ja, da meine ich jetzt vor allem, ich muss es nochmal betonen, ihres Berben. Also ihres Berben, ihres Zeichens Multimillionärin, in mehr durchschnittlichen als guten Filmen mitgespielt, mit einem sehr erfolgreichen Produzentensohn, die den Architekten der Agenda 2010 Frank-Walter Steinmeier zum Bundespräsidenten mitgewählt hat. Gibt jetzt derzeit ein Interview und sagt dort, ja, das ist ja schade, dass die Linke gar nicht mehr sich um die Arbeiterklasse und um die Leute kümmert, die wenig Geld haben. Dann denke ich mir, aber wo hat ihres Berben das je getan? Und wo hat sie das durch ihre politischen Engagements jemals getan?
In ihren Thoughts und in ihren Prayers.
Ja, aber nachträglich dagereicht. Und das finde ich wirklich fatal. Und dass da so getan wird, als sei das jetzt diese dringend notwendige Kritik an den Linksliberalen, die jetzt von diesem Mittespektrum ja kommt, das ist etwas, was anzukreiden ist. Denn ich will noch mal deutlich sagen, es gibt Wogeness, und ich will gleich mal so ein Beispiel dafür geben, und es gibt auch vieles, was ich daran kritisiere. Und es waren ja ursprünglich, um das auch mal hier deutlich zu machen, Linke, die sagten, diese voke, links-liberale Identitätspolitik ist gar nicht richtig links. Zum Beispiel jemand wie Nancy Fraser hat ja schon früh sich eingemischt in diese Debatte und vom 1% Feminismus gesprochen. Also jenen, die Hillary Clinton unterstützen und selbst dick verdienen, die sagen, ja, wir brauchen Inklusion, die aber überhaupt natürlich nie über die Normalarbeitenden nachdenken, nie über die Alleinerziehenden oder so. Diese Kritik am 1% Feminismus kam von links. Viele weitere Beispiele, gerade so aus dem amerikanischen Jacobin-Gebiet, aus dem Kosmos um Bernie Sanders, war eine politische Bewegung und ist sie in gewisser Weise noch immer, die sich mit so einem Vogue-ness Begriff kritisch auseinandersetzte, der eigentlich nur meinte, wir brauchen ein bisschen Diversität in den Vorstandsetagen. Was ja auch eine Forderung ist, der man zustimmen kann. Nur war das ja dann häufig so, das reicht auch schon. Und dann noch vielleicht ein paar Fernsehsendungen, die das abbilden. Und dann ist eigentlich doch alles super. Und genau diese neoliberale Variante wurde kritisiert. Und Nancy Fraser beschreibt ja dann auch diesen Pakt, der da passiert ist. Also dass der Neoliberalismus natürlich in der Weise, in dem er modernisiert, entwurzelt etc. Leuten, die es auch schaffen, erfolgreich sind, dann eine gewisse Diversität zugesteht. Beziehungsweise man das vielleicht sogar noch fördert, weil man herausgefunden hat, ach ja, genau in diesen Szenevierteln, wo so ein bisschen die Verrückten und Alternativen leben, da gibt es auch vielleicht tolle Ideen, die wir wirtschaftlich ausbeuten können. Da können wir auch eine tolle Start-up-Kultur errichten. Dass dadurch so eine merkwürdige Ehe geschmiedet wurde zwischen einer tatsächlich progressiven gesellschaftlichen Entwicklung mit einer wirtschaftlichen Entwicklung, wobei dann die Linken, die eigentlich Linken, immer wieder darauf hingewiesen haben und haben gesagt, naja, das ist aber doch nicht das, warum es eigentlich mal ging. Es ging ja mal um so etwas wie ökonomische Gleichheit. Es ging ja mal darum, dass man die Rechte der Arbeiter stärkt. Und das habt ihr alles vergessen, weil ihr euch nur noch mit diesem Thema auseinandergesetzt habt. Das war eine linke Kritik. Man kann die teilen oder auch wiederum kritisch sehen. Aber was jetzt gerade passiert ist, dass Leute, die sich nie um irgendwelche Probleme von Arbeitern oder sonst wem gekümmert haben, siehe Ulf Poschert oder sonst wer, daherkommen oder jetzt dann auch ihres berben und sagen, ja, also die Linke, die hat die Arbeiter vergessen. So als hätten die gerne Arbeiterthemen thematisiert. Nein, die wollen ja auch die ganze Zeit nur über den Woken-Kulturkampf sprechen, damit sie nicht vielleicht mal über eine Erbschaftssteuer diskutieren müssen.
Also es ist ja kaum etwas leichter zu erklären als das, nämlich dass Superreiche da sitzen und eine Aufgabenteilung unterstellen, in der sich die Linken doch mal um die Arbeiter kümmern, damit es jemand tut.
Ja.
Und wenn die dann ihrem Auftrag, ihrem fremdbestimmten Auftrag nicht nachkommen, dann ist ja wirklich blöd, weil dann kümmert sich ja gar nicht mehr jemand darum und das bedauert man dann. Das finde ich auch soweit amüsant. Wir haben ja heute mit Nils Kumka und Polarisierung ein Buch, das all das adressiert. Und wir sind in diesem glücklichen Umstand, dass wir kurz sagen können, gestern bei Ronzheimer war Maurice Höfgen zu Gast, der natürlich super clever jede Ansprache mit und ihr die Linken und die Linken und du als linker Ökonomen und so weiter einfach komplett ignoriert. Und stattdessen diese eine Lehre aus dem Buch, also es sind viele Lehren drin, aber eine kann man ja mal zentral setzen, man kommt aus der Polarisierung nicht raus, man muss nur die Pole halt neu definieren. Und wenn die einen kommen mit, aber das Bürgergeld, aber das Bürgergeld, aber das Bürgergeld als Thema und als Problem wird immer mitgeschleift, aber die niedrigsten Einkommenklassen, aber die niedrigsten Einkommenklassen, aber die müssen sich doch ein bisschen davon unterscheiden, dass es auch Bürgergeldempfänger gibt. Kommt Maurice Höfgen einfach, ignoriert das komplett und sagt, ja, Binnennachfrage, Wirtschaft allgemein. Die Leute sind zu arm. Sie geben zu wenig Geld aus. Woran liegt das? Sie haben zu wenig Geld. Warum haben sie zu wenig Geld? Ihnen wird zu wenig Geld gegeben. Und macht eine ganz neue Kette auf, also neu für Ronsheimer und so. Für uns natürlich.
Für uns nicht, aber...
Dann kann man sich das einfach mal 40 Minuten lang anhören. Und am Ende, ganz am Ende kommt dann dieser kleine Joke, nur weil Ulf Poscha sich so vehement aufgeregt hat, dass der ehemalige Kanzleramtsminister Wolfgang Schmitt, also Olaf Scholz spät sie, auf Maurice Höfgen zu sprechen kam. Nur weil sich Poscha so aufgeregt hat, saß Maurice Höfgen in dieser Sendung bei Ronsheimer. Was ja auch wieder bedeutet, offenbar kann man dieses, oder das sind so Bro-Podcaster, die sind alle unter sich und haben alle sechs Stille G-Haus einkommen, kann man offenbar hacken, indem man einfach nur...
Ulf Poscha provoziert.
Genau, denn zack, wird genau so über Bande gespielt, wie das ja in dem Kunkum super gezeigt wird, wie man halt über Bande spielen muss, statt einfach direkt die ganze Zeit empört zu sein. In der Hinsicht wollen wir es nicht ganz abhaken, was wir über die Linken in der Zeit gehört haben von Iris Bärben, aber eine Pointe aus dem Buch können wir kurz vortragen.
Willst du schon? Ja, bitte, mach doch ruhig.
Denn es ist, man kann es einfach direkt vorlesen. Es passt so gut, man muss gar nicht groß rahmen. Also wir lesen kurz aus Niels Kumka, wir besprechen das Buch gleich zwei Stunden, da werden alle Details geklärt. Aber hier mal ein Snippet. Aus der Berichterstattung, mittlerweile kaum noch wegzudenken, sind Kommentare, die Umtriebe der politischen Rechten routiniert damit erklären, dass zunächst, blabla auf, oder zumindest gleichzeitig, die politischen Linken einen Konflikt eskaliert hätten, geheimnisvollerweise, da steht in Klammern, geheimnisvollerweise gilt das Verhalten der Linken fast immer als ursächlich, in dem sich nun die gesamte Gesellschaft, außer den Rechten, zu einem übermächtigen linken Block zusammenschließe. Also da steckt alles drin. Ursächlich ist immer, was die Linken tun. Wenn die Rechten dann darauf reagieren, konnten sie nicht andrehen. Genau. Weshalb man auch besondere Vorsicht nehmen muss, wenn man ein ostdeutscher Wahlkämpfer ist. Weil die Ostdeutschen sind ja, wie wir alle wissen, nur Opfer. Also ganz passiv. Und wir haben hier vor zwei Sachen Angst. Entweder vor Ausländern oder vor einem Rechtsdruck. Und an beiden sind sozusagen die Linken schuld. Weil sie entweder die Ausländer ins Land lassen, oder, und zwar weil sie die Ausländer ins Land lassen und dann einen Rechtsdruck gibt, haben die Ostdeutschen wieder Angst vor den Nazis nebenan. Und aus dieser Klammer kommt man natürlich nicht raus. Dass man aus dieser Klammer sehr gut rauskommt, beste Pointen in diesem Buch überhaupt, das ist wirklich ein Spektakel. Ich freue mich sehr, das gleich zu besprechen.
Ich will aber hier auch etwas, ein bisschen Salz reinstreuen, insofern als manchmal der Eindruck jetzt entsteht in einigen Debatten.
Darf ich kurz? Kommt jetzt von der Unterbrechung eh nur anfangen. Ich will einfach nur sofort den kognitiven Anker. Du hast jetzt Salz gesagt. Typischerweise hat man 300, 400 Gramm Essen auf dem Teller. Und das Salz ist so eine...
Ja, aber es heißt ja Salz in die Wunde. Ja, genau.
Das heißt trotzdem, wir reden jetzt wirklich nur über das Salz. Ganz wenig. Der Anteil ist gering.
Ja, ich will das aber doch deutlich machen. Denn es ist schon so, dass wir in einigen Bereichen merkwürdige Debatten hatten und die waren auch zum Teil mal kurz nahe des hegemonialen Diskurses. So, ich will damit jetzt nicht sagen, und genau, gut, dass Iris Berben das aufgeschrieben hat. Nein, eben nicht. Aber wir können ja vielleicht uns mal auf ein Feld konzentrieren, auf das Feld Film, da kenne ich mich nämlich ganz gut aus. Also wir hatten zum Beispiel Frances McDormand, die wird für einen Oscar nominiert, gewinnt ihn auch, hält dann eine Rede, in der sie noch mal am Ende klar macht, zwei Worte muss man sich jetzt merken, Inclusion Rider. Inclusion Rider bedeutete, dass die Zusammensetzung von Cast und Crew die tatsächliche gesellschaftliche Vielfalt widerspiegeln soll. Nun, das bringt uns bei vielen Filmen in die Prédoyer, da die meisten Filme ja nicht einfach nur Gesellschaft widerspiegeln, sondern zum Beispiel von Gesellschaften handeln, die nicht so sind wie die unseren. Also wenn man dort eine Diversität herstellen will, dass man sagt, die sollen aber jetzt alle so repräsentiert sein mit der Gesellschaft. Also man guckt sich die Gesellschaft an, sieht die USA, sagt, die haben so und so viele Eingewanderte aus Südamerika, die haben so und so viele Afro-Amerikaner, so und so viele so. Und dann hätte ich das gerne in einem Film repräsentiert, und zwar vor und hinter der Kamera. Dann enge ich die Kunst extrem ein und verstehe überhaupt nicht, wie Fiktion funktioniert. Und das war ja auch das, was letztendlich zum Amazon Playbook geführt hat, Amazon Prime Playbook, wo ich auch hier dazusage, ja, das wurde auch wieder abgeräumt. Aber das war damals ein sehr stark vorherrschender Diskurs. Wahrscheinlich werden sich viele auch erinnern an die Golden Globes 2020, die von Ricky Gervais moderiert wurden. Und Gervais hat ja dann sich über diese Voken lustig gemacht und hat gesagt, hör zu, wenn der islamische Staat morgen eine Filmproduktionsfirma aufmacht, dann werdet ihr eure Agenten anrufen und fragen, kann ich da vielleicht auch einen Job haben? Also er wollte sagen, das sind Opportunisten, die machen überall mit. Und ich finde diese Rede von Ricky Gervais bis heute noch sehr gut. Was ich jetzt Gervais wiederum vorwerfen kann, dass er dann danach nur noch auf dem Anti-Vogue-Ticket Shows gemacht hat und ganze Abende gestaltet hat, wo man sagen muss, du musst dann auch vielleicht bereits dann auch mal eine andere Seite, nämlich die andere Seite zu kritisieren, zu persifieren, was er dann nicht gemacht haben. Wir haben mitunter obskure Debatten in der Filmlandschaft. Zum Beispiel wird jetzt immer wieder darüber diskutiert, ob Call Me By Your Name ein problematischer Film ist. Pass auf, weil Elio und Oliver, die sind ja ein paar in diesem Film oder werden zu einem. Elio ist 17, Oliver ist 24. Das wird dann als besonders problematisch ausgelegt, wo man auch fragen muss, geht's noch? Wir hatten eine Petition, die verhindern wollte, wo die Ellen-Biografie, Autobiografie auf Deutsch erscheint. Ich bin, also die Leute können das machen. Also können eine Petition auflösen. Ich bin ja für Meinungsfreiheit und bin ich für eine Zensur. Ja, nur will ich sagen, dass das schon ein sehr, sehr vehementer Diskurs war, gegen den ich mich auch stellen würde. Und dass wir dann auch sehr viele Filme bekommen haben, bei denen man ja eine wirklich ganz merkwürdige Vokopolitik plötzlich hatte. Das letzte Beispiel war sicherlich Schneewittchen, dass man dort Schneewittchen nicht mehr von Zwergen sprechen lässt, weil man meint, man würde kleinwüchsige Menschen beleidigen, wenn gleich Zwerge Fabelwesen sind und nichts mit kleinwüchsigen Menschen zu tun haben. Dass wir diese ganzen Debatten haben, will ich hier nicht leugnen. Die Frage ist, wie hegemonial waren sie? Wie massiv waren sie? Ich glaube, es gab eine Zeit, in der sich tatsächlich so ein progressives Hollywood und auch ein gewisses progressives Kapital von der Wall Street, wie Nancy Fraser das beschreibt, verbunden hat mit eben diesen Politiken, die ich jetzt hier angesprochen habe. Dass das aber natürlich nicht dazu führte, dass jetzt so etwas passiert wie unter Wolfram Weimar oder anderen, dass plötzlich Verbote erlassen werden, dies und das. Aber dass man zum Beispiel diese Entwicklung kritisiert hat, finde ich absolut richtig. Und das geht so ein bisschen jetzt gerade verloren. Also manchmal wird jetzt von auch wiederum Linkstiberalen, die sehr auf dem Vokenticket rumgefahren sind, so suggeriert, als sei das eigentlich nur ein Hirngespinst gewesen. Als hätten die Rechten sich das alles nur einfallen lassen. Und das stimmt so auch nicht.
Ich will jetzt nicht in die Falletappen, die ich finde, Gilda Sahibi aus Versehen aufmacht, nämlich zu glauben, ah ja, wir haben eine Emotionalisierung und gegen die hilft eine innertliche Aufklärung. Also ich will keine innertliche Aufklärung machen, sondern eher darauf hinweisen, ich bin sehr gespannt, wie das Ricky Gervais Programm in fünf Jahren aussieht. Wenn man sich nicht über Marga mal lustig macht und so. Das könnte man jetzt schon machen, sonst ist ja alles lächerlich. Aber die Zeit, die du jetzt gerade markierst als, da war es vielleicht sogar mal hegemonial, ist immer noch die Zeit von Nancy Pelosi, Joe Biden, Olaf Scholz und so weiter und so fort. Also wir haben es hier nicht mit...
Nicht mit einer politischen Masse zu tun.
Und Boris Johnson und so zu tun, sondern das läuft auf andere Nächte.
Wir haben es auch nicht mit einer politischen Macht zu tun, die das jetzt... Also das wird ja immer von Rechten dann so getan, als hätten die alle in den Ministerien gesessen und hätten das durchgeboxt. So ist es nicht. Es war ein anderer Zeitgeist. Und diesen Zeitgeist kann man ja auch kritisieren oder zumindest in Teilen kritisieren. Denn es war ja nicht alles an Vorschlägen, die gebracht wurden, falsch und gewisse Inklusionsprogramme zum Beispiel in der Filmlandschaft zu haben und auch andere Mechanismen, wie zum Beispiel Machtmissbrauch angezeigt werden kann oder überhaupt öffentlich gemacht werden kann, dass das alles in die Öffentlichkeit muss. Das ist ja absolut richtig und das ist ja auch tatsächlich der positive Effekt zum Beispiel von MeToo. Aber was wir dann doch gerade in der Kulturbranche stark gesehen haben und ich glaube, das liegt immer daran, dass man eigentlich ja weiß, mit der Kunst bewirkt man gar nicht so viel. Also das große Rat dreht man am Ende doch, wenn man im Finanzministerium sitzt und sagt, nee, gibt kein Geld oder man gibt Geld. Aber dadurch, dass man in der Kultur eigentlich in einer gewissen Ohnmachtsposition ist, glauben Leute, die in der Kultur sind, dass sie immer besonders vehement nach vorne treten müssen. Also sie sind die ersten, die sagen, schließt den Luftraum über der Ukraine. Sie sind die ersten, die wissen genau, wie der Nahostkonflikt einzuschätzen ist. Sie sind die ersten, die sagen, zero, zero Covid. Und genauso haben wir das natürlich auch bei den Inklusionsprogrammen, bei den, ich sage das jetzt mal der Einverhalter, bei den Wogenpolitikern erlebt. Und das hat dann mitunter obskure Blüten getrieben. Und ich will ein aktuelles Beispiel bringen, gar nicht um da eine Einzelperson oder so vorzuführen, sondern was ich eigentlich zeigen will, ist eine gewisse Argumentation, die durch eine gewisse Wogness hineingekommen ist, die ich für falsch halte und gegen die man sich auch stellen kann, ohne dass man in irgendeiner Weise in Verdacht gerät, konservativ rechts oder was auch immer zu sein. Und zwar Bayern 2 veröffentlichte auch so kurze Kultur-Clips bei Instagram und dort werden dann Statements abgegeben zur Literatur oder so. Hier ein Statement Thomas Mann. Wir hören da mal rein.
Man darf von Thomas Mann ja nicht halten, was man will, deswegen kurze paar Dinge vorneweg. Ja, er war ein Meister seines Fachs. Ja, er ist unglaublich wichtig für die deutsche Literaturgeschichte. Und ja, ich kann ihn und seine Werke trotzdem nicht ausstehen.
So, das ist ja erstmal was. Wer hat denn der Meinung zu Thomas Mann? Geh mal auf die Straße und frag die Leute.
Wir hören da gleich mal weiter. Gut, sie mag offenbar die Werke von Thomas Mann nicht. Ich würde sagen, es gibt recht viele Leute, die das auch so sehen. Es ist wahrscheinlich nicht die Mehrzahl in der literarischen Welt, aber es gibt ja schon viele, die sich an Thomas Mann abgearbeitet haben. Mir würde jetzt zum Beispiel Maxi Biller einfallen. Wir hören mal weiter.
Thomas Mann hat die schlimmsten Fans nach Jesus und Fußball. Ich rede so viel über Literatur auf der Bühne, in meinen Büchern, im Internet und bei keinem anderen Autor wird mir so vehement unterstellt, zu dumm für seine Werke zu sein, wenn ich sage, dass ich sie nicht mag. Meinung über Thomas Mann zu haben, scheint überhaupt nicht erlaubt zu sein in der deutschen Literaturszene.
Da wird da so ein Pubkamerad aufgemacht, wir sehen direkt diese Literaturszene, wir sehen die die professuralen Typen, die da sitzen und sagen, jetzt redet da jemand über Thomas Mann und eine junge Frau, kann das denn sein? Das ist ja nicht die Wirklichkeit. Also Thomas Manns Werk wird seit Jahrzehnten auch einer Kritik unterzogen. Zum Beispiel mit Blick auf antisemitische Tendenzen. Zum Beispiel mit Blick auf die unterschiedliche Qualität seiner Werke. Ja, viele können sich auf den Zauberwerk und auf auf Buddenbrucks einigen, aber sagen wir, bei Dr. Faustus sieht das schon anders aus oder bei Königliche Hoheit. Wir haben es ja hier nicht mit einem Autor zu tun, der ohne Sono einfach nur abgefeiert wird. Das ist nicht der Fall. Und als ich mit der Anglistin Lisabeth Bronfen zusammen zum Thomas-Mann-Jubiläum in der Schweiz sprach, sagte sie auch gleich noch mal am Ende, dass sie eigentlich tot in Venedig für ziemlich einen Kitsch hält. Ich habe ihr dann widersprochen, aber das ist durchaus ein Diskurs, der vorhanden ist. Wir hören mal weiter.
Du bist entweder Fan oder du hast es leider nicht ganz richtig verstanden. Aber ich habe es schon verstanden, echt. Thomas Mann war ein Leidender. Dieses Leid war echt, aber er leidet in einem Arbeitszimmer, in dem er sich wochenlang von allen abschotten kann, weil er seine Frau alleine lässt mit der Familie und den Kindern und dem restlichen Leben. Er leidet in einem Haus, das er sich gekauft hat, weil er ein literarischer Superstar war.
Der Vorwurf, der jetzt gemacht wird, Thomas Mann war privilegiert. Ja, stimmt. Aber den Vorwurf kann ich ja genauso auf Virginia Woolf machen. Die ist aus gutem Hause und hatte jetzt finanziell keine großen Sorgen und konnte ihrer feministischen Literatur nachgehen. Ich weiß nicht, ob dieses Argument weiträgt, ist aber ein typisches, dass man in vielen Debatten gehört hat, vor allem dann von linksliberalen Vorgetragen, die oft selbst Privilegien hatten, sie aber verschleierten. Der ist privilegiert, der hat eigentlich gar kein Recht zu sprechen. Wir hören weiter.
Er leidet, während er seinen Nobelpreis poliert. Ja, schwul zu sein und es verstecken zu müssen oder das Gefühl haben, es verstecken zu müssen, ist massiv scheiße. Und ja, Depressionen ist Reichtum und Erfolg meistens komplett egal. Thomas Manns Werken wohnt ein unglaubliches Leid inne. Aber vielleicht sind wir langsam in einer Zeit angekommen, in der das Leid von reichen, erfolgreichen, weißen Männern einfach nicht mehr so wahnsinnig interessant ist. Und vielleicht sind wir dann langsam auch in einer Zeit, in der man Meinung über Literatur haben darf, obwohl sie von Thomas Mann ist.
Ja, im Prinzip übernimmt ja hier die woke Seite die Rhetorik der Rechten. Das wird man ja wohl noch sagen dürfen. Und ich sage mir, ja klar, darf man das sagen. Es gibt sehr viel Kritik an Thomas Mann. Und dass man jetzt sagt, ja, das Werk ist aber vielleicht auch gar nicht so wichtig, weil wir jetzt in einer anderen Zeit sind und uns nicht mehr mit den Problemen eines reichen, schwulen Mannes auseinandersetzen sollen, dann würde ich doch hier fragen, wie viele Werke von Thomas Mann sind denn wohl bekannt? Denn mir fällt zwar auf, dass die Homosexualität in seinem Werk immer wieder eine Rolle spielt und sie wird exponiert, thematisiert in Tonio Kröger und Toten Venedig. Aber bei den Buddenprugs, beim Zauberberg, bei Dr. Faustus Königliche Hoheit, da weiß ich nicht, da wird man homosexuelle Tendenzen drin finden, aber das ist nun wirklich nicht das Thema dieser Romane. Es geht ja um ganz anders. Es geht um große, überzeitliche Menschheitsfragen. Zum einen, es geht um brillante Charakterbeschreibungen, um Figuren, die lange in Erinnerung bleiben. Zum Beispiel auch weibliche Figuren, wie z. B. Toni aus den Buddenprugs. Für alle Thomas-Mann-Leser würde ich fast behaupten, die Lieblingsfigur dort. Wir sind hier also in einem sehr eigenartigen Diskurs, wo man plötzlich die Identität des Autors und auch seine Privilegien und seine Leiden in Einsatz mit dem Werk. Und damit ist aber auch das Werk vielleicht heute nicht mehr zeitgemäß, denn wir haben uns ja geschworen, uns nicht mehr nur mit privilegierten, reichen, weißen Männern zu beschäftigen. Und genau dieser Kurzschluss, und das ist ja nur exemplarisch hier, das ist ja jetzt nicht ein Spezialfall, den ich hier rausgepickt habe. Dieser Kurzschluss, der war in sehr vielen kulturellen Kreisen, wenn nicht hegemonial, doch sehr dominant.
So, Grundbegriff, hegemonial, Diskurs, wie auch immer. Ich sehe so ein Video und denke mir, ja okay, ich sehe hier wieder ein Diskurs, noch irgendwas hegemonial ist. Eine junge Frau hat ein Video gemacht über die Prinzipien und Hintergrundgedanken, die dazu führten. Werden wir gleich wunderbarste Aufklärung erleben bei Kumka. Nun ist das Video da. Du siehst es und spielst sofort über Bande, so wie sie ja auch. Denn sie glaubt ja, es interessiert irgendjemanden noch, wie Thomas Mann gelesen wird, im Sinne von Leute kennen Thomas Mann und haben aber noch eine fluide Meinung. Also sie ließen sich noch durch so ein Video beeinflussen. So, ist ja nicht so. Dieses Video wird von Leuten gesehen, die entweder diese Meinung schon hatten oder nicht haben. Und zu 99,9 Prozent, wenn das auf TikTok läuft oder so, fragen sich die Leute, wer ist Thomas Mann?
Also wir haben es ja hier nicht mit jemandem zu tun, der einfach ein Video gelandet hat. Das ist ja vom Bayerischen Kultursender schlechthin, Bayern Zwei.
Der große Bayerische Kultursender.
Ja, wenn die sich jetzt auf dieses Niveau begeben. Und das haben wir eben in ganz vielen, das haben wir in ganz vielen Bereichen in den vergangenen Jahren erleben müssen. Dass man immer sagte, ach so Moment, privilegiert, weiß, dann kann das auch keine gute Literatur sein, können wir nicht in anderen Filmen besprechen. Also diese Kurzschlüsse, die hier gezogen werden, waren sehr typisch und die sind auch, ich meine, ich kenne Leute, die sind durchaus in ihrer ganzen Lebensweise dem Diversity-Lager zuzurechnen, die genau davon berichten, wie zum Beispiel Kulturförderungen nicht erteilt wurden, weil man irgendwelchen Kriterien nicht entsprach.
Auch so ein Punkt von Gilda, hier alles über Bewusstsein zu leiern.
Das ist nicht Bewusstsein, das ist Realität in Deutschland, in der deutschen Kulturpolitik auch gewesen.
Ja, aber wir müssen jetzt ein bisschen die Lockerungsübung, die uns Kumka sagt, wir brauchen jetzt eine Lockerungsübung. Mein Buch ist eine Lockerungsübung. Die müssen wir jetzt machen. Und ich will zum folgenden Beispiel machen. In Amerika regiert gerade, und es ist immer, der mächtigste Mann der Welt, von dem wir heute sagen, oh, der ist aber irgendwas zwischen dumm und gefährlich, wie auch immer, er heißt Donald Trump. Der legt sich jetzt in Amerika mit der wichtigsten Kulturinstitution des Landes, nämlich den Nationalen Museen, Smithsonian, direkt um, er kann zu Fuß dahin laufen in drei Minuten. So, wir haben also der mächtigste Mann der Welt, und die nun ohne Frage kulturelle Hegemonieinstanz der Welt Amerika, und dort die Gehirnzelle sozusagen, das Gehirn. So, und der Streit dreht sich darum, wer hängt dort in der Porträtgalerie. Denn die Chefin hat gesagt, ja, die sind alle ziemlich pale and male, und das fanden die nicht so witzig im Weißen Haus, und haben gesagt, äh, nö, also, hier hängen bitte nur die allerwichtigsten, und es waren halt Männer und Weiß und so weiter und so fort, und dann sagen die so, nee, wir können ja auch mal normale Amerikaner malen lassen und dahin hängen. So, das gesagt. Wenn du jetzt auf die amerikanische Straße gehst und sagst, was sagen sie zur Porträtgalerie? Sagen die 100 Prozent der Amerikaner grob gerundet, äh, Porträtgalerie, keine Ahnung, was, wovon reden sie und so? Ja, also wenn wir uns auf die Suche...
Ich beschreibe ja auch hier nur ein Spektrum im kulturellen Bereich. Ich bin ja sehr viel in diesen Bereichen zu Hause. Ich weiß, dass das nicht im Sinne hegemonial ist, dass Pentagon und Washington darüber empfinden, dass Pentagon und Weißes Haus darüber empfinden.
Aber Wolfgang, wie groß ist deine Angst, dass, wenn dieses Video irgendwo gespielt wird, dass dann jemand denkt, stimmt, Thomas Mann wird ja völlig falsch beobachtet, ich bin jetzt auf der Seite dieser Frau.
Nein, das ist ja unsinnig. Ich habe ja keine Angst davor. Ich sage nur, dass dieser Diskurs einer war und dem haben ja sehr viele auch widersprochen und auch zu Recht widersprochen. Wogegen ich mich wehre, ist, dass jetzt so getan wird, als hätte es diesen Diskurs nur in den Köpfen der Rechten gegeben. Da würde ich sagen, nein, das stimmt nicht. Und es gab entsprechende Entscheidungen, wie Festivals laufen, wie Professoren besetzt werden und und und. Und es ist immer ein Kampf um die Ideen, es ist immer ein Kampffeld um verschiedene Positionen. Ich male mir ja nicht irgendeine Welt aus, in der alles heil ist und alles schön ist, sondern ich weiß, dass das immer entsprechende Kämpfe sind. Und was ich aber erlebt habe, war, dass sehr viele, die aus einem linken, progressiven Lager kommen und darin auch weiterhin sind, ein Problem hatten mit einer gewissen Voken-Politik, ich nenne es der Einfachheit halber einfach Voke-Politik, die sich sehr stark in kulturellen Institutionen ausgebreitet hatte, die nicht mehr über z.B. Form sprechen wollte von Werken, sondern erst mal nur gefragt hat, von wem sind sie und wie ist die Identität etc. Und das hat viele auf die Palme getrieben. Ich will ein Beispiel geben, will das anonymisiert machen. Ich saß mit jemanden zusammen aus der Kulturbranche, der selbst das absolute Feindbild eigentlich der Rechten ist. Ja, der lebt nicht heteronormativ, der lebt in einer Regenbogenfamilie, verschiedene Konstellationen, will ich jetzt nicht alles ausbreiten. Und er sagte zu mir, als wir in einer Bar saßen, also zum Teil hatte man wirklich den Eindruck, da gibt es so einen Boken-Stalinismus. Der sagte, also jemand, der dir mit einer Perlenkette um den Hals gegenüber sitzt, spricht plötzlich so. Und natürlich war das eine Überschwitzung von ihm. Und er ist auch nicht irgendwie ein Feind gegen all das, was jetzt hier aufgeführt wurde. Ist nicht ein Feind dessen nur. Aber was er sagte, war, dass es diese Tendenz sehr stark gab. Was jetzt für mich aber nicht bedeutet, dass ich sage, diese Tendenz darf es nicht geben. Nur, würde ich sagen, man muss erst einmal angekennen, dass es sie gab. Und ich habe ja auch immer wieder in Filmanalysen gewissen Tendenzen widersprochen. Und habe auch dann zum Beispiel darauf hingewiesen, dass das wahrscheinlich wenig zweckdienlich ist, wenn man jetzt einfach nur Werken unterstellt, weil sie von dem und dem geschrieben wurden, sind sie nicht gut. Sondern es wäre ja viel interessanter, sich zum Beispiel auch in so einem Video mit dem Werk von Thomas Mann kritisch auseinanderzusetzen. Zum Beispiel, wie ich das mit Elisabeth Bronfen getan habe. Wir haben nämlich über Dr. Faustus gesprochen und haben zum Beispiel auch darauf hingewiesen, dass da doch eigenartige Darstellungen sind bezüglich Antisemitismus. Und das ist etwas, was ja stattfinden soll. Und ich bin ja nicht da in irgendeiner Weise, dass ich sage, lasst bitte alle auf dem Sockel stehen, alle großen Denker. Aber das ist, man hat es sich sehr leicht eine Zeit lang gemacht. Und die Beispiele, die ich eben genannt habe, so aus der Filmbranche eben auch. Und ich glaube, dass das ein Diskurs war, der auch sehr viele verärgert hat. Und damit muss man aber jetzt nicht bei Ihres Verben ankommen und sagen, die Linken sind an allem schuld. Und deshalb überhaupt haben wir Donald Trump und die AfD.
Ich will es mal so sagen. Ich schreibe mir jetzt mal ein euch Ideen-Dasein zu. In den Kreisen, in denen ich mich auch hobbymäßig noch über Sachen austausche, also wir in der Bar, nach unseren Auftritten, wir beim Schnitzelessen, ich mit meinen ehemaligen Soziologie-Kommilitonen, wie auch immer so, das, was wir heute als Aufklärung bekommen, nämlich das ist, und das haben wir ja schon von Steffen Mauer gesagt bekommen, da geht ja Kumka sehr drauf ein, Leute haben eine ganz andere Meinung und eine ganz andere Einstellung als das, was wir sehen, wenn die Kognition einmal durch die Kommunikation geleiert ist. Da greifen also kommunikationseigene Prinzipien, die irgendetwas abbilden, was man, wenn man demoskopisch an die Sache rangeht, gar nicht findet. So und in den Kreisen, in denen ich mich bewege und am liebsten aufhalte, war das, was du jetzt als ich nenne es mal Vogue, noch nie zu keinem Zeitpunkt etwas anderes als absolut lächerlich.
Ah ja, aber das ist ja eine andere Haltung, wenn du jetzt mit dieser Haltung zum Beispiel...
Und mit absolut lächerlich meine ich auch absolut ungefährlich.
Genau, aber wenn du jetzt mit dieser Haltung zum Beispiel auf eine Dokumenta gehst oder bei irgendeinem Theaterfestival...
Ich war ja auf der Dokumenta und ich habe mich über jedes Ding da aus... Also wirklich, ich hätte überall einen schwarzen Link drüber gehangen. Ja, das sah aus wie so eine Kinder-Sache.
Ja, du bist aber...
Ein Klassik-Kunstprojekt oder so sah das alles aus. Manches war echt von Müll in Kassel nicht zu unterscheiden.
So, aber genau mit diesen Aussagen würdest du erheblichen Ärger bekommen, wenn du in diesen Institutionen auf einem Podium wästest und sagst, du kannst das hier so schön sagen...
Ja, lass mich diese Parante machen. Diesen Ärger würde ich nur bekommen, weil Leute mir unterstellen würden, dass auf mich jemand hört und diese Meinung übernimmt. Wenn es nur um meine Meinung ginge...
Ich glaube, man würde das schon als solches problematisieren.
Wenn jemand von mir als einzelner Wortbeitrag beleidigt fühlt, da könnte ich mir vorstellen, der Künstler selbst, klar. Aber jemand anderes, der auch durch Zufall gerade in Kassel ist, ich dachte, ich feier auf meine Dokumenta, hört mich dann, wie ich mich drüber lustig mache und sage, oh, das ist aber krass, das ist so eine krasse Meinung. Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Das ist die Stimme eines privilegierten Europäers. Wir wollen dir nicht länger zuhören.
Wenn das auf der Ebene der, da hat jemand eine Meinung bliebe, wäre alles gut. Nur weil wir immer unterstellen, der hat nicht nur eine Meinung, sondern, und das ist ja im Fernsehen sehr beliebt, das war ja auch zum Beispiel als wir Aufwachen-Podcast gemacht haben, mein Ansatz war ja immer anders als der von Tilo Jung, weil Tilo ja immer der Meinung war, wir müssen jetzt die Aufwachen-Hörer darüber aufklären, was im Fernsehen eigentlich stattfindet, weil der normale Fernsehzuschauer ist ja doof, nur wir durchschauen es und müssen es jetzt aufklären. Und diese Unterstellung, dass die anderen ja alle leicht empfänglich für, was macht der Bayern 2 da mit so einer komischen Frau, die irgendwas zu Thomas Mann sagt. Die Realität ist, auf dieser Meinungs- und Einstellungsebene, es interessiert niemanden. Aber Realität ist eben auch, sagt Nils Kumka. Auf kommunikativer Ebene muss es gar niemanden geben, der auch weiß, wer Thomas Mann ist. Allein, dass diese Frau unterstellt mit dem Label, hier spricht Bayern 2, es gäbe da einen Diskurs und es bestünde eine Gefahr der Hegemonie. Und morgen werden alle Bilder von Thomas Mann falschrum im Museum aufgehängt.
Aber darum geht es ja jetzt noch nicht. Also ich sage, dass es Diskurs- und Kommunikationssimulationen gibt und dass das auch so funktioniert in einem Medienbetrieb, ist mir ja vollkommen klar. Ich wollte ja nur darauf hinweisen, dass es sie gab. Es war jetzt mitunter so, dass man so tat, als hätte das wirklich nur in den Köpfen der von Rechten stattgefunden. Und das ist so nicht richtig. Und was ich ja zum Beispiel feststelle, ist, dass das ja eine Diskussion war. Die wurde vor allem geführt, ich würde mal sagen, also wenn wir ein paar Jahre zurückgehen, wo dieses Denken sehr präsent war. Ich sage jetzt nicht Berlin Mitte, Mainz aber auch. Also es wurde geführt in Ende.
Also ich finde, wir können jetzt schon mal alles namentlich nennen.
Nein, lass es.
Aber nicht mehr virtuell bleiben. Mach es konkret.
Nein, das war so Ende 30, Anfang 40, Ende 40. Das war so eine bestimmte Gruppe von Leuten, die machten ein bisschen Kultur, ein bisschen Podcast, ein bisschen Marketing und so weiter. Und für die war das jetzt plötzlich, nachdem sie irgendwie gemerkt haben, ich bin ja selbst auch relativ privilegiert, so ein Thema und da sind die auch unglaublich drauf rumgeritten und haben sich dann nochmal so selbst verwirklichen können, so eine zweite Pubertät durchlaufen, sage ich mal. Wenn ich jetzt aber zum Beispiel mit jüngeren Leuten zusammen bin, also die Anfang 20 sind, für die ist das überhaupt in dieser Weise gar kein Thema. Die sind viel offener sowieso schon an sich. Und für die ist das, also in dem Bereich, in dem ich mich jetzt befinde. Also beispielsweise komme ich ja gerade aus Mainz zurück, ich war gestern Abend in Mainz, da wurde der wunderbare Billy Wilder Film Sunset Boulevard gezeigt und ich habe dann darüber gesprochen. Da sitzt natürlich niemand, da sitzt nicht eine 22-jährige im Publikum und sagt, das finde ich aber jetzt problematisch, dass wir dann einen Film von einem alten weißen Mann oder so gucken.
Vielleicht denkt sich das trotzdem.
Nein, nein, es ist ein völlig anderer Diskurs. Es sind ganz andere Fragen, die kommen, es ist eine ganz andere Diskussion. Und da gebe ich dir Recht, es gab da eine Diskurssimulation und die war auch eine, die sehr elitär war, denn sie wurde von Oscarkandidaten und von irgendwelchen Leuten, die gute Stellen in irgendwelchen Fernsehanstalten haben oder so geführt. Und das ging sehr an der Sache vorbei. Ich wollte nur mit diesen Beispielen aus der Filmbranche, weil ich mich da ein bisschen auskenne, darauf hinweisen, dass es diese Entwicklung tatsächlich gab. Manches war davon positiv, aber vieles war auch zu kritisieren. Und dass dies auch weiterhin stattfinden darf, auch wenn gerade Donald Trump der mächtigste Mann ist oder so, finde ich, sollte auch dazugehören. Also man kann nicht nur so tun, als gäbe es da so ein Problem, das ist das Einzige, was wir noch reden können.
Also Filmbranche ist schlagkräftig, weil da kommen echte Casting-Entscheidungen, echte Budget-Entscheidungen, aufgrund echter Management-Entscheidungen zustande. Und denen kann man unterstellen, dass sie so ein Fähnchen im Windzeitgeist folgen, und dann passiert so was wie dieses Playbook. Ich will nur als abschließenden Gedanken, bevor ich noch klips, die uns dann zum Buch führen, sagen, wenn wir Horst und Hopf hören, arbeiten die sich immer an irgendetwas ab. Die haben zuletzt über Abtreibung gesprochen, da haben sie ein Video gespielt, von dem sie vorher sagen, so war es ja nie die Probleme, die da beschrieben wurden, aber wir spielen es mal trotzdem, weil wenn es so wäre, dann wäre das ja voll krass und dann wäre das Video auch voll richtig. Und es wird genau so, fast wird wirklich gesagt. Also völlig absurd. So, wir lesen in diesem Buch wieder, Curtis Jarvin hat so diese Cathedral-Vorstellung. Wir lesen diese Aufklärung über, die Linken sind immer schuld, weil die Mitte sich vorstellt, dass die Rechten nur erfolgreich sind, weil die Linken irgendwas machen, aber wir sind ja die Neutralen und so. Also jeder ist in so einem imaginären Dings verfangen. So, wenn ich aber Diskurses suche und ich sie ja auch finde zum Thema, was weiß ich, Klimawandel. Richard David Brecht sagt, wir werden das Jahr 2200 nicht überleben, die Menschheit. So, dann haben wir hier ein Thema gesetzt, das relativ unabhängig, also eine Wahrhaftigkeit relativ unabhängig davon hat, wie das jetzt problematisiert wird. Im nächsten Robin Alexander macht im Marktwechsel Podcast eine Aufklärung darüber, für wen das jetzt ein Problem ist und warum man dann überbande so und so. Und das ist ja eigentlich auch total verständlich. Also wir haben unhintergehbare Diskurse, von denen ich sage, die sind legitim. Und dann haben wir Diskurse, die wir davon unterscheiden müssen, wie zum Beispiel da irgendeine junge Frau äußert sich.
Es geht mir auch gar nicht immer um dieses Video, da muss man gar nicht drauf rumreiten. Aber du hast jetzt eben gesagt, du hast dich drastischer zur Dokumenta geäußert, als ich das wahrscheinlich getan hätte. Ich habe die nicht besucht, aber wahrscheinlich in dieser Drastik hätte ich mich gar nicht ausgesucht. Ich habe gesagt, das meiste war von Müll nicht zu unterscheiden. Und da hätte man natürlich ja drüber hängen sollen.
Das sah aus wie in unserer Waldorfschule, in der dritten Klasse damals.
Und da ist doch die interessante Frage, die sich daran anschließt. Warum ist es zu diesen Werken oder zu der Auswahl dieser Werke gekommen? Und da würde ja eine Kritik ansetzen. Und die hat dann auch eben mit gewissen, zum Beispiel identitätspolitischen Paradigmen zu tun, die sehr dominant sind, zum Beispiel bei Kuratoren der Dokumenta oder anderen Kuratoren, die dann zu kritisieren sind. Und das ist aber nicht etwas, was ja von Rechten oder so nur gekommen ist. Die sind später erst auf den Zug aufgesprungen. Sondern es gab von links auch eine Kritik an solchen Dingen. Es gab von links viel früher eine Kritik an einem wohlfeilen Diversity-Diskurs, der die eigentlichen Ausbeutungsverhältnisse ignoriert. Dietmar Dard hat hier in dem Band, den ich mit Ann-Christin rausgegeben habe, selbst schuld, auch darüber nochmal einen Text geschrieben. Und das ist nun wirklich niemand, der sagt, ich bin Anti-Wolk oder so. Das ist ja völlig unsinnig. Und da muss man sich auch nicht eingemeiden lassen. Aber diese Art der Auseinandersetzung war etwas, was zum Teil äußerst schwierig wurde. Und das sind aber nur, wie du richtig sagst, spezielle Bereiche. Wenn man nicht auf der Republik ist, wird man es kaum mitbekommen.
Ich bin für vehemenz. Wir haben diese Lockerungsübung. Demgegenüber, man kann auch eine Festigungsübung machen, dass man sagt, also in der Porträtgalerie der amerikanischen Geschichte hängen nur Männer, weiße Männer. Weil das waren die Präsidenten, die CEOs, wer auch immer. So, dann kommt die Museumsleitung und sagt, wir könnten ja auch mal normale Amerikaner abbilden. Dann wird irgendwie so eine Idee, also so eine Person halt. Und dann hängt halt ein Zettel dran. So sahen übrigens 90 Prozent der Leute, dann hat man so eine Schirze und jemand steht in der Küche oder wie auch immer. So, wenn wir jetzt einfach sagen, und das ist eben jetzt wichtig für die Zukunft, dass man nicht wieder in dieselbe Falle tritt. Denn wir wollen ja nicht Maga und März so besiegen, dass es Pendel wieder überschlägt. Das wäre ja total doof, wenn es immer hin und her pendelt. Wir können nicht immer nur zwischen Weltkrieg und Vereinten Nationen hin und her pendeln und alle 50 Jahre das wiederholen. Deswegen müsste man jetzt, und da ist Kumpkas Buch eben sehr gut, das werden wir dann gleich lesen, einfach ein paar Pflöcke einschlagen. Wenn wir sagen, in der Geschichte spielen bislang Männer nur eine große Rolle, weil, und dann kommt es eben auf Raffinesse und wissenschaftliche Unterstützung an, Frauen andere Rollen zugesprochen bekommen haben, die wir aber nicht auf kommt-in-die-Portrait-Galerie hoch einschätzen.
Genau, das waren die patriarchalen Strukturen.
Dann muss das einfach mal ein thematischer Fakt sein, genau wie koloniale Ausbeutung und so weiter, die man sich nicht nur weil irgendwelche Maga oder Märzleuter und so weiter unzufrieden sind, wie auf amerikanische und deutsche Geschichte geschaut wird. Also wir haben ja auch die Nazi-Zeit gut abgeschüttelt, obwohl alle so traurig waren, dass wir einen ganz wichtigen Krieg verloren haben. Wir blicken ja heute anders darauf. Dann muss man das thematisieren können. Und zwar aus der, ich sag jetzt mal richtigen Seite, so, dass man sie ein bisschen abschottet gegen die Prinzipien der Kommunikation der anderen Seite. Und das geht. Ja. Und das geht aber nicht, indem man einfach, und da muss ich leider sagen, das Buch von Gilda Saevi ist nicht so gut, einfach das Vorzeichen umdreht und sagt, da halten wir uns voll dagegen und klären mal inhaltlich auf. Ihr seid ja viel zu emotional. Das ist nicht der richtige Weg. Also wir haben heute ein Buch, das ist sehr gut beschreibt, und dann haben wir als Kontrast dazu ein Buch, das ist halt, in das ein oder andere Fettnäpfchen tritt, von dem uns Kumka sagt, nein, da nicht reintreten. Dann geht es halt weiter wie bisher. Dann haben wir einfach nur die richtige Polarisierung, im Vergleich zur falschen, obwohl Kumka ja selbst sagt, wir könnten durchaus richtig polarisieren, denn aus der Dichotomie kommen wir ja sowieso nicht raus. Also in der Ansicht, heute haben wir die Chance, echte Aufklärung zu leisten über dieses sehr gute Buch von Nils Kumka. Ich will es nochmal sagen, wir besprechen es gleich.
Dann machen wir das.
Jetzt aber politische Kommunikation. Drei Clips oder vielleicht noch zwei, je nachdem wie die Zeit läuft. Isra Klein erklärt hier, finde ich, wie immer, sehr aufgeklärt, was Kandidaten im politischen Betrieb jetzt kommunikativ leisten müssen, um nicht einfach Anti-Mager zu sein oder Anti-Vogue, weil die Unterstellung, dass die anderen einfach alle Mager sind. Nein, nein, nein. Das ist ja Triggerpunkte, wenn man sie wirklich fragt. Die Leute, die sind nicht alle Mager. Das schaukelt sich noch kommunikativ so hoch. Also muss man jetzt kommunikativ runterschaukeln, um die Leute abzuholen, wo sie sind, nämlich nicht Mager. Und er kommt über diese Beispiele jetzt in New York und so. Mandami, wie kommunizieren die und warum ist das richtig?
What you need is not like the one recipe. You need candidates who are compelling on their own.
So on their own. Die also sich nicht abgrenzen von das finde ich blöd, ich bin der Antitrumpf, sondern ach so, du bezahlst so viel im Supermarkt, dann mache ich dir selber einen Supermarkt.
Also nicht Hillary Clinton. Hillary Clinton war das einzigen Versprechen, ich bin nicht Donald Trump.
Und ich bin eine Frau. Also das nützt einem gar nichts, dass Hillary Clinton eine Frau ist....
kompelling on their own, is that they know who they are and they're willing to stand up for it. And sometimes that is to the left of where, you know, much of the electorate is comfortable with them being, and sometimes it's like a little bit to the right, but there is something about being willing to unleash the energy of some conflict around yourself, right? Not being so...
So, der Konflikt, aber der sich um die Person dreht. Also nicht jetzt große thematische und so weiter, Die Person muss unterscheidbar sein von anderen Angeboten im politischen Diskurs und dann ihr Angebot voranstellen, das natürlich in der Politik im Konflikt, daraus kommen wir nicht raus, das sagt ja Nils Kumka auch, sehr eindrichtig. Der Konflikt ist der maßgebliche Treiber....
careful and cautious and pole-tested and mealy-mouthed, that everybody feels when they hear you talk. Like the first thing happening in your mind is a filter that is catching anything you might say that anyone might not like first. People really sense when they're not quite talking to you.
Ja, die Leute spüren, wenn du nicht direkt zu ihnen sprichst, sondern dieses Spiel über Bande machst. Da hinten ist noch eine Laufkundschaft, die ist noch zu überzeugen. Und zwar die 50-jährigen Eingewanderten aus Indien, die bisher noch nicht abgeholt wurden von Maga. Da haben wir noch Potenzial. Und dann hältst du eine Rede zum Thema, bla, bla, bla. Und alle stehen vor dir und fragen, was gerade? Ich versteh's nicht, die sind nicht meine Wellenlänge.
Und wenn du mit Mama Donny sprichst, oder ihn hörst, sprichst du mit ihm. Wenn du mit Guy Ego sprichst, oder ihn hörst, sprichst du mit ihm. Oder das ist wahr für Angie Craig, das ist wahr für Lee Slotkin. Es gibt viele gute Kandidaten, aber eine Sache, die diese Kandidaten haben, ist eine Authentizität. Und du siehst mich und denkst, ja, Ich würde diese Person immer weiter hören.
So, das war auch das Erfolgsding von Christian Lindner. Du verdienst über 100.000 Euro im Jahr oder möchtest es? Ich senke deine Steuern. Punkt. Das war das ganze Angebot. Tiefer wurde der Diskurs nie mit den Wählern der FDP. Jetzt hören wir im Kontrast dazu Lars Klingweil, der nichts davon beherzigt, von nichts eine Ahnung hat, sondern einfach nur, ich bin ja als Finanzminister und so. Und die Vorzüge seiner Finanzpolitik und seiner Mitgliedschaft in der SPD uns erklärt. Und der Clip geht 26 Sekunden und ist Tiefschlaf für alle.
Das oberste Ziel dieser Regierung, das will ich noch mal betonen, ist, dass wir Arbeitsplätze sichern, dass wir Deutschland auf den Kurs des wirtschaftlichen Wachstums zurückbringen und dafür auch sorgen, dass am Ende die Arbeitsplätze hier sicher sind und neue geschaffen werden können. Wir verbessern das Leben der Menschen. Wir sorgen mit Investitionen dafür, dass neue Jobs entstehen können, dass es faire und bessere Löhne gibt und dass das Wohnen in unserem Land ein gutes Stück wieder bezahlbar wird.
Aber auch nur ein gutes Stück wieder.
Ein gutes Stück bezahlbar, was auch immer. Man hört das und man ist sofort wütend. Und man sucht geradezu, kann bitte jemand meine Wut aufgreifen? Und dann steht natürlich die AfD da und sagt, wir hassen ihn noch mehr als du.
Und das will ich schon mal vorwegnehmen. Wir müssen gleich mal über die Mitte sprechen. Das hier ist so ein Mitte-Sprech, der macht mich so aggressiv, der radikalisiert mich in einer Weise, wie ich es kaum aussprechen kann.
Ja, aber selbst hier, also 16 Prozent, das ist weder hegemonial noch sonstig, das ist einfach nur durch Demokratie-Mathematik in Finanzminister-Posten gekommen.
Jaja, ich weiß, ich weiß. Aber trotzdem...
Selbst in der Partei nur 60 Prozent.
Aber trotzdem ist er jetzt dort.
Ja, genau.
Also er hat jetzt diese Macht da.
Ja, aber das ist eben dieser Punkt, nur weil wir etwas sehen und alle unterstellen sogar die verfassungsrechtliche, wissenschaftliche Literatur sagt, der ist ganz mächtig, heißt das noch lange nicht, dass das hegemonial ist. Sondern das ist Anschlussfähigkeit Null.
Ja, wenn du jetzt nur über Diskursen...
Funktional begründet, ja. Aber in der Ansprache...
Aber der hat ja wirkliche Macht. Also das ist ja eben der Punkt, den du eben richtigerweise gemacht hast. Wenn da jemand gesagt hat, ich finde Call Me By Your Name problematisch und man sollte den Film nicht mehr zeigen oder so. Das war nicht hegemonial. Das waren einzelne Stimmen und die wurden vielleicht dann sozial-medial verstärkt. Aber hier sitzt ja jemand in der entsprechenden Behörde, der sagt, wir bringen irgendwas ein Stück weit voran und wir wissen ganz genau, er tut das nicht.
Genau, dann ziehen wir nämlich mal die, das ist wirklich mächtig, dann ziehen wir mal Bilanz in vielen Jahren, wie viel Stücke die Mieten gesunken sind. Und schließen daraus mal, wie mächtig dieser Mann war. So, jetzt nochmal Esra Klein.
Naja, weil er es gar nicht will. Also das wäre ja, das ist ja schon eine Unterstellung.
Darin steckt schon mal diese große Lüge, nur weil jemand etwas sagt, heißt das noch lange nicht und so weiter. So, Esra Klein zu genau dieser Frage.
Was ich nur sagen will, diese Art des Sprechens von Lars Kringbein und ganz vielen anderen, und das verbindet ihn ja auch mit CDU und mit anderen Parteien, die so sprechen, das ist ja eines, das auf Mäßigung aus ist, das so sagt, hier spricht die Vernunft, alles in Ruhe und Gelassenheit. Darin steckt selbst ein Extremismus, würde ich sagen. Das ist auch ein Wir und die anderen. Ja.
So und jetzt, wie sollte man eigentlich sprechen?
One other thing I want to say about Mondani, that I've always found to be a big part of his appeal and what makes him a real political talent, is he feels very motivated by his sympathies and not his resentments. That's not, in my view, how Donald Trump feels, but it's also not how a lot of people on the left feel. Oftentimes people in politics, they feel more motivated by who they hate than who they're in this for. And Mondani, who took a lot of flack, right? You know, who got a lot of unfair attacks. Nevertheless, there is a fundamental friendliness to his campaign. A sense that even if you disagreed with him, he didn't hate you. He wasn't looking to push you out of his circle. He wanted you in there. He wanted you in that tent. And that idea that there is a political value to what you might call a high political theory level pluralism and what you might call a normal human being, like friendliness and openness to other people, I think that's easy to underestimate. I think that a real failure of the left, and I don't just mean like the democratic social left, I mean like the broad left of the center, was developing a politics that seemed like it was more interested at times and a communication style, and figure out who wasn't on our side and making that clear, than inviting people, even people who didn't agree with us, in at least halfway. And Mom Donny, though he's into a lot of people's left, he doesn't feel that way. He's looking for where you agree with him, not where he can kick you out.
So, nun ist so, Kumpka klärt uns gleich auf. Ja, die Politik führt zu kollektiv bindenden Entscheidungen. Und die Willensbildung innerhalb der Partei ist so auf Gemeinwohl ausgerichtet. Und das ist schon ein sehr inkludierendes kollektiv binden. Das gilt ja wohl für alle, ja, stimmt. Aber es wird immer auch Leute geben, die mit einer Entscheidung unzufrieden sind. Und der Trick ist, sie dann trotzdem daran zu binden. Und diese Gemeinwohlsache ist nun klar Wahlkampfrhetorik. Denn das, was Esa Klein hier sagt, hat eine dunkle Seite, über die uns Kumka gleich aufklärt. Und es lautet wie folgt, wenn du eine politische Ansprache für jemanden machst und sie so ehrlich meinst, dass jemand sich wirklich verstanden fühlt und sagt, genau das ist, was ich brauche, ich nehme dein Angebot wahr und an, dann funktioniert es nur, wenn dieses Angebot für jemand anderen, Poantin Kunkar, gefährlich ist. Nur dann funktioniert es. Was bedeutet, Donald Trump war nicht aus eigener Kraft durch die Unterstützung seiner Bays so erfolgreich, sondern weil er für die anderen so gefährlich schien, hat er mobilisiert. Er hat also klar polarisiert. Und Kunkar sagt, wir kommen aus diesem Polarisierungsgebot nicht raus, denn wir können keine Politik über Langeweile machen. Das geht einfach nicht. Vernunft, Gemeinwohl, kollektive Bindung, ist alles Langeweile. Niemand interessiert sich für den Ablauf des Verwaltungsprinzips, wo dann wirklich kollektiv bindende Entscheidungen hergestellt werden, sondern erst wenn längst entschieden wurde, heißt es, das finde ich aber ganz blöd jetzt.
Du hast völlig recht. Also wir werden jetzt gleich darüber diskutieren. Es gibt noch einen anderen Ausweg, aber den verrate ich nachher. Und den verrät Kunkar auch so mal ganz kurz. Es gibt einen anderen Ausweg, den ich nicht als meinen Ausweg vielleicht definieren würde, aber der ist auch noch da. Und der hat mir am meisten eigentlich zu denken gegeben von allem, was ich so gelesen habe. Also wir sprechen über Polarisierung von Nils Kunkar. Das steht also an und diskutieren dann auch Verbinden statt Spalten, eine Antwort auf die Politik der Polarisierung von Gilda Sahibi. Man kann jetzt, wo wir die beiden Sachen gelesen haben, durchaus sagen, das ist das Gegenbuch zu Kunkar. Außerdem gibt es von mir wieder ein Musik-Tipp, diesmal Tchaikovsky. Dann habe ich den neuen Roman von Leif Rand gelesen, der heißt Let's Talk About Feelings. Dein Buch Allegro Pastel war ja ein großer Erfolg und jetzt schauen wir, was Leif Rand zu erzählen hat in seinem neuen Roman, der in der ganz nahen Zukunft spielt, aber die Möglichkeit ist ein bisschen verschoben, denn die Bundesrepublik wird von einer Bundeskanzlerin regiert und das ist so ein progressives Lager, aber das ist kein politischer Roman in dem Sinne. Dann habe ich Gedichte gelesen und zwar von…
Laut oder leise?
Ich lese sie gleich mal laut, habe sie aber auch leise gelesen. Zheng Xiaoxiang, ich hoffe, ich habe das richtig ausgesprochen, ist eine chinesische Wanda-Arbeiterin, die irgendwann anfing, Gedichte zu schreiben, die dann Erfolg hatten, auch in China, auch übersetzt wurden in andere Sprachen. Und jetzt ist ein Band von ihr erschienen, der heißt Erzählung von den Konsumgütern. Und sie macht Lyrik aus den Produktionsprozessen, aus den Menschen, die dort arbeiten, wirklich sehr, sehr beeindruckend. Außerdem habe ich einen Text gelesen, der sich damit beschäftigt, was hat eigentlich Donald Trump in Venezuela vor? Ja, wir haben das ja von Recht gehört.
Die Schiffe sind schon unterwegs.
Und jetzt sind schon Schiffe unterwegs. Und es wurde schon ein Schiff torpediert. Was ist da los? Ich habe also eine Analyse dazu dabei. Und wir fragen uns, wie war das jetzt eigentlich bei diesem Will Smith-Konzert, bei den Konzerten, die er hatte in Europa. Da ist ein Video bei YouTube erschienen mit begeisterten Fans. Und es wird darüber diskutiert, ist das etwa alles AI generiert? Und sagt aber hier ein Autor, nee, es ist eigentlich noch viel schlimmer.
Okay. Sehr gut, da bin ich gespannt. Wir lesen den Brief von Frauke Brosius-Gerstorf. Ich will die Poente gleich verraten. Das ist im Grunde Bewerbungsschreiben auf das Amt der Bundespräsidentin.
Okay.
Also meine Leser. Dann eine sehr große Studie. Die ganze Welt wurde untersucht. Wir haben doch alle dieses u-förmige Zufriedenheitsbild. Wir werden geboren, sind relativ zufrieden. Dann kommen die Mühlen der Ebene. Wir müssen Kinder erziehen und Ausbildung und alles. Wir sind sehr unglücklich und am Ende wieder fröhlich. Gibt es nicht mehr. Aber jetzt wird einfach unzufrieden geboren. Und danach kann man hoffen, dass es besser wird, aber schwierig. Und da wurde wirklich Stichprobe 1,7 Millionen und so. Da geht es weltweit zur Sache. Und dann ein Text. Ich trage ihn vor allem vor, um Fragestellungen zu formulieren. Zum Thema Homophobie. Denn die New York Times klärt auf über Donald Trumps Big Gay Government. Es gibt schwule Bande in der republikanischen Partei und der neuen Regierung, die ganz offen sagen, das ist unser Club, so heißen wir, hier gibt es Mitgliedschaftsregeln. Ich bin zwar hier nur so unter Staatssekretär, aber ich bin der Pascha im Net Club, den gleich kennenlernen wirst. Genau, Peter Thiel macht immer große Partys, zu der man, also eingeladen bei Peter Thiels Party ist so ungefähr wie Stanford-Zusage. Danach ist das Leben anders.
Und warum Homophobie? Also dagegen richten sich dann andere in der republikanischen Partei?
Also zum einen geht es darum im Text selbst, dass es natürlich noch Schwule in Washington gibt, der schwulsten Staat der Amerikas, die mit denen nichts zu tun haben wollen und sich wirklich abgrenzen davon, wenn die die auf, wo man sich herum trifft, sehen und das herausfinden, dass die aus diesem sofort Ende Gelände. Und ich möchte eine allgemeine Argumentation soziologischer Natur, warum es überhaupt mal zur Homophobie kam oder warum auch Frauen ausgeschlossen sind, warum hat die Kirche sich immer so krass zölibärter organisiert und so. Will ich jetzt noch mal aufwerfen, da wir sehen, dass hier, ich will es nicht sagen, geheime, aber schwule Bande in Regierungsnähe befinden. Denn da gibt es ja historische und funktionale Argumentation, die zumindest mal ein paar Pointen bereithalten, wenn nicht sogar einiges aus der Vergangenheit erklären. Aber sei gespannt.
Dann sehen wir uns jetzt gleich im Salon. Den Salon kann man ganz einfach buchen, indem man auf die Seite neuzwanziger.de geht. Dort ist ein goldener Button. Da steht Salon drauf und klickt man darauf, kommt man gleich zu Steady und kann eine Mitgliedschaft anwählen. Ab drei Euro im Monat ist man dabei. Wir empfehlen eine Jahresmitgliedschaft. Das ist günstiger für die, die buchen und auch für uns, was die Zahlungsdienstleister anbelangt. Wer schon bei Patreon ist, kann das auch dort einfach buchen. Und für die Apple-Kunden, wie funktioniert das da?
Man ist im Grunde, man hört hier über sein iPhone, über die Apple-Podcast-App und dann taucht dann der Salon einfach im normalen Feed, den man eh schon abonniert hat, auf. Nur halt mit einem 3,99-Button. Da kann man dann buchen.
Und dort sind natürlich auch alle alten Folgen. Das gesamte Archiv, das ist bei Steady zu finden, aber bei den anderen ist auch sehr, sehr viel da. Und man hat natürlich auch die Salons, die Live-Salons, die sind auch überall zu hören. Also zum Beispiel der vergangene Sommersalon.
Ja, macht euch ruhig auf die Suche. Bei Steady gibt es ein paar Vorteile.
Ja, das sowieso. Und wir wollen noch darauf hinweisen, dass wir ja dann in diesem Monat uns nochmal hören. Es gibt ja noch den Live-Salon und der wird selbstverständlich dann auch noch diesen Monat veröffentlicht. Ich will noch ganz kurz darauf hinweisen, dass ich am 14.9. in Krefeld zu Gast bin. Da ist eine Podiumsdiskussion über Kunst. Ist Kunst anachronistisch geworden? Das ist dann die Frage und dann bin ich im Thomas-Mann-Museum, im Buddenbrooks-Museum, so muss ich richtig sagen, in Lübeck die Woche darauf zu Gast. Das findet man aber auf meiner Homepage dann. Und da geht es dann auch um Männlichkeitsbilder bei Thomas Mann.
Das würde ich ja mal problematisieren. Was müsste ich da bayerische Rundfunk überhaupt ein bei Thomas Mann?
Das sollen die in Lübeck klären.
Am 19.9. machen wir Live-Salon. Vorher gibt es die Stadtführung von Mary. Den Link zum Anmelden für limitierte 15 Plätze gibt es gleich zu Beginn im Salon.
Bis gleich.